Es ist ein fragwürdiger Baum mit fiesen
Fragen und sehr harmlosen Fragen,
die grünen Arme, die roten sind
fies, ja, es ist eine Show für dich, es ist ein bisschen
knifflig, aber nur Gottes Wahrheit, ja, nur
schalte es aus, reiß die Laschen ab, ja, okay,
lass uns hier reingehen  harmlos
das ist nicht harmlos wie gehst du
mit haufen von fans um mädchen slash groupies
hängt von meinem status ab ich würde vorsichtig sagen
ich werde davon abhängen Ich meine manchmal hast du
Lust nach einer Show zu feiern und du wirst
eine Party schmeißen und und du wirst geben
Viele Backstage-Pässe ausgeben und dafür
sorgen, dass dort eine große Party
stattfindet und alle Spaß
haben. Manchmal bist du ein bisschen müde, weißt du
, vielleicht hast du
am Abend zuvor ein bisschen zu hart gefeiert und dann
gewonnen  An diesem Abend ist keine Party und das ist
, denke ich, wie ich mit Fans/
Mädels/Groupies umgehe, also wachsen die fünf
durch die Front her sind mit der Party
Ich denke, die ganze erste Reihe ist ab und zu auf der
Party und
manchmal sind sie nicht ok  ay ein roter dieser rote
ist für dich ah ja ein bisschen anmaßend
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das bedeutet dass Chad steht warum
ist geld das wichtigste für
dich wer sagte das ich glaube du sagtest deine
ex freundin was sehr viel geld bindet
von dir und so stellt sich heraus, dass
sie weiß, was dein schwächstes ist nein
es tut es nicht es bedeutet mir nicht wirklich
viel eigentlich bedeutet glück mir am
meisten also ja es ist es ist es nicht
es ist nicht das geld wenn es für das wäre
Geld hätten wir schon vor langer Zeit aufgehört
,
aber da wir nicht wissen, es geht
darum, Musik zu machen, meine ich, und es ist
derselbe Grund, warum die Rolling Stones
weitermachen, weißt du, weil sie überhaupt erst
anfangen und wann du
weißt  Vier Jungs kommen in ihren Teenagerjahren in eine Garage
und ihr seht euch an
und sagt, wie großartig es wäre
, in einen Tourbus zu steigen und um
die Welt zu reisen und unsere Songs vor
Tausenden von Menschen zu singen und sie
sie uns zurücksingen zu lassen  das muss das
geilste gefühl überhaupt sein und i
Du bist immer noch da,
also Leidenschaft ist das Wichtigste
Glück ja okay eine Frage zum
Schluss du kannst grün oder rot wählen okay
nur für uns also nur für dich bist du so ein
Nicht-Klischee-Rocker warum das
Sarkasmus sein muss oh und so  Die Welt sagt, dass die
Deutschen keinen Sarkasmus verstehen. Ich glaube nicht
, dass wir verstehen. Manchmal sind die
Klischees lustig. Du denkst, deine
Sache oder dein Ding
Weißt du, das kann
manchmal klischeehaft sein, aber es liegt nur an
der Art und Weise, wie du es drehst. Du weißt, dass
es ein großartiges, großartiges Zitat gab, das von
Angus Young von ac/dc kam, ja, und der
Interviewer sagte, Angus, findest du nicht, dass
dieses Album viel klingt?  wie dein letztes
Album und er sagte, Freund, wir machen seit dreißig Jahren
das gleiche Album,
falls du es nicht bemerkt hast,
und unsere Fans scheinen sich überhaupt nicht darum zu kümmern,
und er sagte, ich weiß nicht einmal, das ist Andy the
Interview direkt dort eine andere
Frage stellen das Interview  hier, weil sie sich
bei Ihnen bedanken und Ihnen eine gute
Zeit in Deutschland
wünschen